We need you strong.
Okay.
Come on, let's go.
Ain't sure what we're gonna find out here, Dutch.
We have to try. Stay close. We'll do our best to stick to the trail.
This goddamn weather.
Been two days or more like this now. Oh, it has to blow over soon.
Come on.
Get up, old.
Careful over this bridge here.
Can't believe we lost Davy, too.
He's the last one, Arthur. No more.
We need to get those people warm and fed.
At least we don't need to worry about Pinkerton's tailing us in this.
A couple more days, we'll be on the other side.
You need to help me pick the others back up.
You're the only one I can rely on to stay strong right now.
We got fire and shelter. That's a start.
And what about the money?
Please tell me.
You at least got the money before it all went to hell on that boat.
Hey, I think I see something up the path.
You up ahead. Who's there?
Micah.
Gentlemen.
Found anything?
I think so. Found a little homestead down that way.
Okay. Anyone home?
Sure. Place is blazing with light and noise. Sounded like a party.
Let's go see.
Follow me. How's Davy doing?
He didn't make it. Nor did little Jenny.
That's too bad. Davy was a real fighter. Both of them calendar boys is. Or was.
Yeah.
And Mac, Sean, we don't know...
Quite a business.
I'm glad you're all right, Micah.
Always.
Ask him if he's seen John.
Hey, have you seen John, Micah?
Didn't see much of anything once this storm came in.
He hasn't seen him.
He'll be fine. Things always turn out right for that boy.
I hope Mac and Sean are still out there somewhere, too.
Hey, Arthur, let me take the rear. You move up.
Whoa.
You run into anybody else?
I reckon we're the only ones crazy enough to be out in the woods.
I'm sure.
It's crazy enough to be out in this, Morgan.
Yeah, well...
Don't talk to me about crappy.
Aw, so no, glad you're all right.
I was worried, Micah.
Look.
It's all gonna work out, Morgan.
We lost a few folks.
But that's just how it goes, sometimes.
Well, I'm glad you're feeling so good about it.
Where are all the other?
Old mining camp back up the hill.
Ain't much, but it's shelter.
So, this house, you speak to the...
Okay, let's keep it down now, gentlemen.
It's just up ahead.
Snuff and stash those lanterns, boys.
Best you two lie low on this.
Boom!
Okay, let's head down there.
Let's hitch up here.
Hey, give me that!
There you are.
Let me handle this.
We don't want to spook these fine people.
Sounds like quite the party.
You two, get yourself out of sight.
One lonely man is a lot less intimidating than three nasty-looking degenerates.
Arthur, in that cattle shed on the left.
Micah, get down behind that wagon in front.
Let's go, Micah!
Let's go!
Hello?
Shut up, Billy.
Excuse me!
Hello?
Oh, hello, friend.
What you want?
I am very sorry to disturb you.
My friends and I, well, we got into some trouble up the way, lost in the storm.
We're going to need some help.
Gentlemen!
We can't help you, mister.
I got folks dying on the trail.
Arthur, Arthur, we got a problem.
Aww.
Folks?
There's a corpse right here.
Now, I just need some cans of food.
Arthur, there's a body in the wagon.
Or something.
I hear you. Just keep your eyes on Dutch.
Please.
I think you should go now, buddy.
Now, friend, I ain't asking for much.
Please.
I am kind of desperate.
Hey, I don't believe it.
Come here, partner.
Come here!
It's goddamn Dutch Vandal in your...
Shit! Look out! There's more of the bastards!
Watch out!
Boys, we got here first!
What up, John?
I don't know!
That's how you want to do it?
You sons of bitches!
Somebody's making a run for it!
Arthur!
You Ka Breeder!
Where is everyone going?
I know that dude from Edha, everybody's calling driven bodies.
I'm not saying到 이러까...
And also, just look at Da-Tacon.
He winning out there?
Uh...
Hey, like, I ain't mad at ya, but...
I actually made this up for now.
I, uh...
Oh, you don't need that.
pas et est.
If it's gonna shapes up to be mah 800th day.
Well, that's like...
Think about all that.
What do you need so much...
Why don't you...
How's your Twitter's doing...?
Uh, my Twitter's broken.
That's my boy, Arthur.
Go shoot him.
Goddamn, O'Driscoll boy's here.
Why?
I don't know.
Maybe same reason as us.
Micah, go bring the horses closer to the house.
Arthur, let's go search the cabin.
Arthur, get in here.
Smells like a party in here.
Turn the place upside down.
Grab as many supplies as you can.
We need the essentials.
Food, medicine, whiskey.
O'Driscoll's.
I don't believe it.
It's a strange place.
This one all right.
Maybe they're hiding up here, too.
There's a big price on Colm O'Driscoll's head.
Nearly as big as the one on yours.
One Colm dead is about the only thing me and Uncle Sam agree on.
Oh, I'm starving.
You should eat something now.
Get your strength up for the ride back.
You messed with me.
What do you mean ?
I pulled up the table.
Looks kind of naked.
All in one little pile ever since you see me.
What's going on ?
I'm chili.
You're chili ?
You can't be...
Tracy talkedchwagg...
Why you kinda likeore?
To be honest, our money
Thirty bucks.
It was that one you said I had it anyway.
That was a deal.
But I thing you paid player's
You're a man.
Keep searching while I pack these on the horses.
Meet me out here when you're done.
I'll be right back.
Hmm.
Poor bastard was married too.
What are you doing in there, Arthur?
Just give me a minute.
Hmm.
I'm sorry.
Arthur, go see if there's anything in that barn.
Micah, you search the cabin. See what we missed.
Sure.
Are you going to check that barn?
You bastards shot my cousin!
Well, he started it.
I'm going to break your neck!
What's going on?
This guy just killed me!
Oh, did he now?
Sneaky little bastard. Should I kill him?
No.
Not yet.
Find out what they're doing here and where Colm is.
Oh, this son of a bitch will talk.
Oh, come on.
Where's Colm, old Driscoll?
With the others.
In old mining camp southwest of here, near the lake.
I'm sure he's got a good idea.
What are you bastards doing?
Why are you up here?
We're fixing to rob some train.
Gonna blow the tracks.
I don't know more than that, I swear.
Well, I would say it looks like you have this, Arthur.
Do what you want with him.
I don't care.
But bring that horse when you're done.
I don't know anything else.
Please.
I'm sorry.
Please, partner.
Just let me go.
Come on.
I just do what I'm told.
Please.
Get the hell outta here!
Go!
Whoa.
Easy, easy.
Make it easy, then.
You're alright, boy.
You let him go, huh?
Saw the little bastard scurry and all.
Yeah.
Figured he won't get far in this anyway.
That looks like a decent horse.
You should keep him.
You need to hitch him.
He's already skittish.
Get away from me!
Micah, what the hell do you think you're doing?
Don't you...
Why don't they get you?
Leave her alone.
I wasn't doing nothing.
She's one of them odriscos.
No, she ain't, Micah.
Look at her.
Miss, miss.
Are you...
Oh, you fool.
Micah.
Miss.
Now, it is gonna be okay.
We mean you no harm.
Miss.
Come on.
It'll be okay.
We need to get out of here.
And quick.
Come on, now.
You okay, miss?
They came three days ago.
And my husband, they...
Okay.
Miss, you are safe now.
And you can't stay here.
You come with us.
Carson.
Miss.
It's okay.
We're bad men.
We ain't them.
It's okay.
Get on.
We'll keep you safe until you figure out what you want to do.
What's your name, miss?
Miss.
Adler.
Sadie Adler.
Mrs.
Adler.
I...
He...
He was my husband.
Hey!
Somebody's coming!
Looks like it's Dutch.
Hey, everybody.
Dutch is back.
How'd you get...
with me?
I made some hard
zione in Cannibal's maison.
Yeah!
Sand.
Anyway,
do you know where he went?
You don't need to know this.
This village has no place for us.
I...
And we love you guys.
But only four,
take care.
strands of the a lanyard.
Dan,
soul, Mrs. Adler.
Miss Tilly, Miss Karen, would you warm
her up? Give her a drink or something?
And Mrs. Adler,
it's gonna be okay.
You're safe now.
They turned her into a
widow. Animals.
I need some rest.
I haven't slept in three days.
You're over here.
Miss O'Shea will show you the way.
Mr. Morgan, we put you in a room
over here. Thank you, Miss
Grimshaw. Mr. Bell, you're with
the fellas over there.
How come Arthur gets a room
and I get a bunk bed next to Bill
Williamson and a bunch of darkies?
Get yourself to bed.
He ain't been seen in days.
Weather ain't let up.
He's strong.
And he's smart.
Strong, at least.
Hello, Arthur. Abigail.
Arthur,
how you doing?
Just fine, Abigail.
And you?
I need you to...
I'm sorry. I'm sorry to ask, but...
It's little John. He's got
himself caught into a scrape again.
He ain't been seen in two...
two days.
Your John will be fine.
I mean,
he may be as dumb as rocks
and as dull as rusted iron,
but that ain't changing because
he got caught in some snowstorm.
At least go take a look.
Javier?
Yes.
Javier, will you ride out with Arthur
to take a look for John?
You're the two best fit men we've got.
Now?
She's...
We're all...
Yeah, we're pretty worried about him.
I know.
The situation were reversed and...
and...
he looked for me.
He looked for me.
Thank you.
This way.
Last I know,
John was headed up the river.
For all we know,
he kept riding north and never looked back.
He wouldn't leave.
Not like that.
Uh, wouldn't be the first time.
Especially with him.
He certainly was the sandwiches boy.
Yeah.
JustキЦ
opinion.
Pretty curious and seine
we would've glue us all together in time
if it wasn't city filings.
Like I told you,
Well, it seems somebody left recently.
And that way.
Sure, Will. Come on, then.
There's some tracks leading to the river.
Ha!
Let's cross. See, they continue up that way.
Where you going?
Eh, despacio.
Ha!
You think it's John?
You tell me. These are horse tracks for sure, but it could be anyone.
Let's just see where they lead.
So, you were there, Javier.
Yeah.
What really happened on that boat?
We had the money. It seemed fine.
Then suddenly they were everywhere.
Bounty hunters?
No, Pinkertons.
It was crazy. Raining bullets.
Take it slow. Big ravine here.
Dutch killed a girl in a... bad way.
It was a bad situation.
That ain't like him, though.
We'll continue along the cliff wall here.
Davey got shot. Mac and John, both shot too. Sean, we don't even know.
I'm surprised we escaped at all. By the time you boys showed up from the other side of town, we were only just holding on.
Bad business, all right.
Damn snow's coming in hard and...
We'll lose these tracks if we don't move fast.
What are you doing?
On kg-mousey道 c deixajesu and ae
Va'ona
Kem uunscu
Come on, boy. Horses are getting tired.
Yeah, a lot of fresh snow here.
I don't know about this, Javier. We can't follow nothing.
Let's push on a little bit. Maybe we'll pick up the trail again.
Almost there, boy. Come on now.
Hey, look! Over there! You see that?
John was riding that horse when we left Blackwater.
Let's see if he can hear us.
Come on! Up there!
It's coming from up ahead somewhere.
I don't think we can go much further on this.
We're going to have to get out of the horses.
We have to walk from here.
I'd grab that shotgun from your horse.
Who knows what's up ahead.
Getting that gun, then?
Down this way.
You're going to have to move a bit faster.
It's slippery. Be careful.
We're high up here.
You're telling me.
Tell me!
Drops down here. Watch yourself.
Careful here.
Stay low under here.
Okay, from here.
Watch your step. This is real slippery.
Stay close to the wall.
Up here. Come on.
Get up here.
Over.
bez
jal
That sounds closer now.
Come on!
over.
We're coming, John!
Dang, it's cold!
Let's keep moving, then. Come on.
John!
I'm here! Out on the ledge!
That's John! We're coming!
The fella's there!
John!
Down here!
All right! Hot down, Marston!
He's down here.
That's quite a scratch you got there.
Never thought I'd say this, but good to see you, Arthur Morgan.
You don't look so good.
I don't feel too good, neither.
I'm freezing.
Don't die just yet, cowboy.
Come on, compadre.
Well, we can't go back the way we came.
Let's try this way.
Ain't you a sorry sight.
Camp? I'll argue with you there.
See?
I told Dutch you weren't the right man for this.
I'm sure you did.
You all right?
I don't think so.
Come on.
Hopefully this will lead us out.
Look up there.
Shit.
scene 6
First try,
You rocks.
You're gon' forget this is no fantasy.
Youан has a哅 Jones response.
Go for it.
Ham version.
I will do it.
Second try again.
Nice.
Iastes a compare with Thorne's.
Start your attack.
почти all the way.
You need a wee bit of practice to play 3 An zest.
You can't reflects.
Fix usual game that is free.
Basically, you fascinating only to me-
The kind of me I want.
Hey, a better nori.
Starting to th 1941 full time.
Keep them away from us!
Hold... stand!
No!
We're out of them all!
Good work, Arthur.
Okay, let's get going!
We're out of them all!
Before any more of these bastards show up!
Quick! Before any more show up!
We're out of them all!
We need to leave! Now!
Go!
Come on, then!
Let's get back to the others!
I don't feel too good.
You'll be fine.
It's just like a dog bite.
You knew a fella?
Got bit by a dog.
Died. An hour later.
You ain't gonna die!
Not yet.
Up there!
More of them!
Get out of here!
Shit, there's more on the right!
More coming in on the left!
Go!
Get the hell out of here!
Get out!
You see any more, Arthur?
Don't think so.
Jesus!
You still with us, Marston?
Just about.
You're gonna be okay, Arthur.
We have some shelter now.
Thanks for coming for me.
Of course.
That bullet in Blackwater, now this.
You had a hell of a time.
And Arthur always says,
I'm lucky.
None of us are lucky right now.
We should ride in the water for a bit.
Try to lose a scent.
Don't wanna leave a trail right back to camp.
You know, we're gonna need to come up with a better story for that scar.
So, freezing, bleeding, starving,
damn near getting eaten to death ain't good enough for you.
Here, let's cross to the left.
Yeah, come on.
Let's push hard and get back.
See those buildings up ahead, John?
That's where we camped.
Nearly there.
Come on!
We're almost there.
Someone help John down off this horse.
Can we get some help here?
Can we get some help?
We need some help here!
Come on, help him down.
You're alive! You're alive!
Here we go. Here we go.
Ah, you careful, idiotas! It's his leg!
Come on, let's get you warm.
Thank you. Thank you both.
This is a new low, even by your standards.
Thank you, Arthur. Thank you.
You got any other lost maidens need saving?
Not today.
Have you and Dutch talked about how we're gonna get out of this?
I was just discussing with Herr Strauss
when the weather breaks, I suppose we'll have to keep heading east.
East? Into all that civilization?
I know.
The west is where our problems are worse.
Come on, Herr Strauss, let's get warm.
Thank you, Mr. Moggy.
We've been runnin' for weeks.
We found shelter and
been restin' here in some
old abandoned mining town while we
wait the thaw.
Hardly the spring I had been hopein' for.
hardly the spring I had been hopein' for.
So what now, Dutch?
We get strong, we get warm, and we wait.
When the storm breaks, we move.
But we're safe here.
Warm enough.
I guess.
You sound doubtful.
Not doubtful, just worried.
We have been shot at before, Jose.
I don't feel that this is honestly anything new.
I hope not.
We had a bit of bad luck, but then the storm covered our tracks, so now we wait a bit.
Then we go back to Blackwater and we get our money, or we get some more money, and we keep heading west.
But we're heading east.
For now.
We got this.
We're safe.
Stay safe.
We're strong, Jose.
Stay strong.
We're safe.
We're free.
We're fine.
We're safe.
We're fit.
We're fine.
We can move ship.
I don't know.